in this off-white color I have a handful
of statements that you might hear folks
say especially in the United States and
we're going to think about is are these
statements that you ought you would
typically hear from a liberal and I'm
gonna make a little key here so I'm
gonna use a light blue for liberal
conservative I use this salmon color for
conservative or a libertarian sounds
this white color for libertarian
libertarian and I've pre grouped these
statements into categories they could be
views on social issues or economic
issues and within each of those
dimensions they could be views that
might want more social or economic
control or ones that want less social or
economic control and this isn't a
perfect full sampling of all of the
major issues that folks will talk about
and some of these things kind of border
on social and economic or some of them
could be viewed as more control
depending how you view it or less
control but this is a a first take on
things so let's just go from the top
left to the bottom right and I encourage
you to keep pausing this video and
coming to your own conclusion so this
first statement affirmative action is a
good thing would you expect that to come
from some of the liberal conservative or
libertarian ideology well this would
typically come from someone with a
liberal ideology much of the ideas and
policies that liberals would favor might
be around curing social injustice so
they might say hey we don't have the
proper diversity in certain walks of
life right now we don't have a level
playing field so we need to make sure
that people are properly represented and
so that would be something that you
would hear from liberals and it would be
something that in general involves more
control a libertarian or a conservative
would say hey you know we shouldn't try
to do social engineering here we should
maybe make sure people have equal
opportunities but that doesn't mean that
you have to have equal representation
and outcome in this next statement
marriage should be between a man and a
woman pause this video who is likely to
say that well that would typically come
from someone with a conservative
ideology this would be around the theme
with that many folks with conservative
ideologies would
- values that are worth preserving in a
society that should not change and so
that would typically come from them
while a liberal or libertarian is more
likely to say hey what goes on between
two people well that's their decision
and really the government should have no
say on what they do we need tougher
penalties and policing to deal with
crime
well once again that would be something
that you would likely hear from someone
with a conservative ideology a liberal
or libertarian would be on the opposite
side they would say hey I'm afraid of
too strict penalties too strict policing
I'm afraid that the government is
putting too many people in jail so now
let's go to less fewer social controls
so marijuana should be legalized pause
this video who is more likely to say
that well many liberals would be likely
to say that and also libertarians they
would say hey you know the once again
what someone does and within in their
own privacy why should the government
have a say while many conservatives and
this goes back to values and kind of
social fiber might say well no but some
of these drugs they break down people's
value system maybe they lead to crime
and so a conservative would be more
likely to be against legalizing
something like marijuana the next
statement laws restricting gun rights
are unconstitutional and won't have the
intended impact pause this video who
would say that well you would often hear
a statement like this from someone with
a conservative ideology but also from
someone with a libertarian ideology so
the libertarian ideology would also say
something like that and they would both
cite that people have a right to protect
themselves they might cite hey people
have a right to use guns for things like
hunting and especially libertarians
might make the argument that people need
to be armed in order to protect
themselves from an overly strong
government from an overly strong police
state so the next statement same-sex
couples should have full marriage rights
who's most likely to say that well this
is kind of the opposite statement of
this one we saw up here and for the
reasons we mentioned this is more likely
to come from someone with the liberal
ideology
or a libertarian libertarian ideology
and for them it would be about personal
liberty and equal rights and so you
might already see some trends that the
conservative and liberals are kind of
mixed on the social when it comes to
more control or less control and don't
read too much into how many there are of
each this is just you could view it as a
random sampling of some issues if I
sampled more you might have more liberal
boxes up here or more conservative boxes
down here but it seems like a mix but
one clear thing that comes out is that
libertarians on the social dimension are
for less control but what about the
economic dimension so this first
statement everyone has a right to
quality health care who's more likely to
say that well that would be a liberal
liberals once again they think a lot
about injustice and inequality and they
want the government to be proactive
about it and so they would say hey the
government should somehow supply
universal health care to folks
conservatives or libertarians
not that they don't care about injustice
or inequality but they would argue that
hey when the government kind of
intervenes in things they don't they
have all sorts of unintended
consequences and oftentimes do more harm
than good the next statement rent
control is a good thing well once again
this is likely to come from a liberal
probably motivated from the idea that if
rents or living costs are getting too
high that this is a way to avoid people
being displaced or being priced out of
their neighborhood now conservatives and
libertarians would argue that rent
control distorts the market it actually
makes the properties that aren't on rent
called rent control overly expensive and
so it's probably doing more harm than
good
the next statement social safety nets
are crucial
once again this is likely to come from
someone with a liberal ideology they
believe that someone that the government
has a role in making sure that everyone
has a basic standard of living so
programs like food stamps or welfare
every worker has the right to a living
wage and living wages sometimes you'll
hear this in the context of minimum wage
discussion
who would say that well once again
you're likely to hear this from someone
with a liberal ideology they believe
that higher minimum wages are a good
thing while conservatives or
libertarians would argue that no that
distorts the market and actually you
might increase unemployment and you
might hurt the very people that you are
trying to help with some of these
efforts around minimum wages and what
about here would we go to less control
on the economy government intervention
in the free market will slow the economy
hurting everyone well as you can imagine
this is kind of the opposite statement
as these here because these ones on the
top are all the government intervening
in a free economy in some way and so
this statement is more likely to come
from a conservative some of the
conservative ideology or a libertarian
and so when you look in the economic
dimension the distinction between
conservative and liberal at least when
it comes to more control and less
control becomes more clear on economics
liberals tend to favor more control more
government intervention with the focus
of trying to address social or economic
inequality or environmental concerns
while conservatives and libertarians
will often say well no that's gonna do
more harm than good the government does
have some functions but it should really
be as small as possible and free markets
are what's in the end of the day going
to make people better off so I will
leave you there this is a very simple
model but it helps us start to think
about these issues and so when you think
about issues and you read about it in
the newspaper try to think about it in
this type of a framework